[Música]
es el momento de hablar de salud en
directo a América y para ello me
acompaña Mario Romero salas mar Buen día
para usted Buenos días Ángela lo
habíamos predicho ayer que el mic nos
iba a dar más de qué hablar y por eso
hoy Vamos a continuar con ese tema este
fármaco diseñado para atacar la diabetes
que últimamente se ha popularizado para
perder peso si ha llegado a viralizarse
sobre todo en países como Estados Unidos
donde Además está escaseando
precisamente vamos a empezar explicando
de qué se trata este medicamento el
componente activo es la semaglutida que
está fabricada Además del fármaco por la
farmacéutica novo nordisc y lo que hace
es limitar el azúcar en Sangre y también
controlar los niveles de insulina por
eso como decías es un medicamento que
está pensado para las personas que
sufren de diabetes tipo 2 que es el tipo
de diabetes adquirido se aprobó en
Estados Unidos con este propósito en
2017 y si no lo cubre un seguro médico
llega a costar 892 dólares
aproximadamente al mes es decir no es un
medicamento particularmente barato Qué
pasa que uno es carísimo sí uno de sus
efectos secundarios es afectar la
percepción del hambre reducir el apetito
y también ralentiza la velocidad a la
que se vacía el estómago por lo que la
sensación de saciedad dura más así que
es común que con estos efectos se pierda
peso no que la persona que toma Este
medicamento termine perdiendo peso es
por eso también que con esa misma
farmacéutica con este propósito
desarrollo
Exactamente lo mismo con una dosis un
poco mayor y está aprobada y regulada
únicamente en este caso para perder peso
no para tratar la diabetes y lo están
tomando personas tanto que han recibido
por sus médicos la recomendación de
perder peso como personas que
simplemente quieren adelgazar Pues por
motivos estéticos esto tiene muchísimas
consecuencias ahora las vamos a
desgranar pero una de ellas por ejemplo
es que las personas que toman we gobi
cuando se acaba este medicamento acuden
a os en pic porque es lo mismo en una
dosis más baja y las que necesitan este
medicamento para tratar su diabetes no
pueden acceder a él una mina de oro para
una farmacéutica en el mundo que está
lleno de complejos con la obesidad y
Exactamente Bueno hay grandes magnitudes
de pérdida de peso son significativas
hablemos de eso sí revisamos las cifras
de un estudio publicado en el living
journal of medicine que básicamente
evaluaba los efectos de la semaglutina
en dosis de 2,4 miligramos semanales es
una dosis bastante alta Durante un año y
medio había dos grupos de participantes
que recibían una inyección semanal un
grupo recibía un placebo otro grupo
recibía el fármaco y las diferencias
como decías son muy significativas en el
grupo placebo el cambio de peso era de
un descenso del 2,4% había además
intervención en hábitos no en dietas en
ejercicio también y en el grupo que
había tomado el fármaco era del casi el
15% la reducción en el peso corporal de
los participantes además la proporción
precisamente de participantes que
perdieron al menos un 10% de su peso fue
un 12% en el grupo placebo perdón pero
casi 70 en los que tomaban semaglutida
por eso claramente con estas cifras ahí
esa percepción como de una cura
milagrosa especialmente eso en una
sociedad no donde perder peso siempre va
a ser visto como una cosa positiva y
como una enfermedad no el exceso de peso
bueno precisamente por esta percepción
de cura milagrosa porque el peso no es
una enfermedad tampoco Omar sea
popularizado en redes y entre los
famosos que es lo más terrible del caso
exactamente de hecho le llaman el nuevo
medicamento de Hollywood Hay muchísimas
personas famosas que lo están tomando o
que están hablando de eso al menos y
quizás una de las más famosas ha sido
precisamente el empresario y ahora pues
casi que Magnate y lo más que cuando le
preguntaron en Twitter cómo hacía para
mantenerse tan en forma durante pues
durante todo este tiempo contestaba que
lo hacía con ayudo con ayuno y con
wigobi este medicamento que es digamos
lo mismo que os explique en una dosis
más alta la semaglutida aprobada perder
peso como Este es un ejemplo Pero hay
muchísimos y también hay muchísimos de
personas que en redes como tiktok o
Instagram personas anónimas están pues
grabando su proceso tomando os en pic o
tomando we gobi y por ejemplo la
etiqueta de tiktok os en Pick
simplemente tiene ya más de 600 millones
de
visualizaciones Y la verdad al menos
personalmente después de estar revisando
estas redes es especialmente preocupante
no están llenas de imágenes de personas
que claramente no se sienten bien con su
propio cuerpo que no tienen cuerpos
hegemónicos que pueden ser consideradas
gordas por la sociedad y que están
intentando tomar esto para encajar no
también en unos criterios estéticos
entonces Bueno es un reflejo realmente
revisar estas redes sociales de muchas
de estas cosas que están mal alrededor
de este medicamento esos videos parecen
una publicidad que había al menos
preguntarse si Existe algún tipo de
patrocinio lo cual Pues bueno agregaría
no a este problema y el consumo de
no es inocuo si vamos a terminar con Los
Fuertes efectos secundarios que tiene
este medicamento al menos para que todo
el mundo sepa Qué sucede si tomas este
medicamento no para empezar las defectos
más comentados son las disrupciones del
tránsito intestinal causando náuseas
vómitos diarreas o incluso también
estreñimiento además como reduce el
nivel de azúcar en sangre en personas no
diabéticas puede llegar a provocar
mareos o visión borrosa y ya aumentando
el nivel digamos de gravedad de los
efectos secundarios y algunos casos
puntuales en los que provocó inflamación
del páncreas problemas con la vesícula
biliar e incluso también se sabe que
propicia la aparición de tumores de
tiroides por eso está desde el principio
contraindicada para personas que puedan
ya estar predispuestas a desarrollar
este tipo de cáncer claro todos estos
riesgos pueden tener algo de sentido si
hay un acompañamiento médico si hay una
supervisión por ejemplo en pacientes de
diabetes tipo 2 que sabemos que tener
una diabetes descontrolada también tiene
muchísimos efectos nocivos pero cuando
salimos de ese grupo de personas
entramos en un problema y es como
decíamos no ver el peso definitivamente
como un problema de salud que si
desaparece el peso desaparecen todos los
demás problemas o riesgos de salud sin
ver todo lo demás que se puede pues
sacar de este medicamento No todo lo que
conlleva también llevándose por delante
quizás muchísimas otras cosas a las
cámaras mostrando cuerpos hetero
normativos y por detrás vomitando y